my name is Rene Rivera and I'm the vice
president of research and economic
development at Montana State University
when we look at timing in the early
embryo it's very precise so in moving
from one cell to two cells it should
take about eleven plus or minus four
hours the time from two to three cells
should actually be very similar and then
the third and the fourth cells should
appear within one hour of each other and
so what's interesting to me about that
is if those timings don't occur very
precisely throughout development one may
have fewer cells of a particular type
formed so for example if a basal layer
of cells needs to form before neurons
can form if there's too few basal layer
cells then you get fewer neurons and
diseases like Parkinson's disease are
caused by the loss of a population of
cells or a small number of cells and so
you can imagine if you start out life
with fewer neurons of one type you could
lose them more rapidly and get Park in
early onset Parkinson's so we're
interested in that relationship between
how cells form in early development and
how they're lost over time to lead to
visa to disease clearly there's a link
between the number of cells were born
with and our ultimate disease State